you may be used to a ride hail driver
picking you up and taking you to your
destination but just where are they
headed some with the help of their
companies have been spending time on
college campuses earning degrees and
preparing to forge new careers
correspondent Chris Van Cleef has the
story
it's a moment Richard Spann thought was
Out Of Reach for a 73 year old Uber
driver hi Julie the Army veteran and
great-grandfather is celebrating his own
college graduation self-esteem is high I
never thought I'd go to reach it it's a
dream you see how it never really
grasped but then when it comes it's
wonderful span is among 130 Uber drivers
graduating from Arizona State this year
thanks to a partnership between the
company and the university providing
free tuition for online degrees since
2018 nearly 700 have completed college
there are a lot of people who earn with
Uber who know they've never gone to
college no one in their family has ever
gotten a college degree this opens up a
door that they never had open to them
before how important was this Uber
program oh my God they were
they were just absolutely essential for
me where I am today it's a big step
towards keeping a promise to his mother
he's now aiming to get a PhD in
criminology I can be called Dr Spann
like my mom always wanted me to be she
wanted me and I want her to be proud of
me span plans to keep driving for Uber
all while showing his
great-grandchildren it's never too late
to chase your dreams for CBS Saturday
morning I'm Chris Van Cleave in Phoenix